alors on va maintenant ouvrir la
deuxième page de ce club des territoires
on va revenir avec vous ça venir sur
l'audition hier au sénat du ministre de
l'intérieur gérald darmanin et de la
ministre des sports amélie oudéa avait
castéra auditionné par les sénateurs sur
ce fiasco de l'organisation de la finale
de ligue des champions samedi soir au
final après près de trois heures
d'audition qu'est ce qu'on a appris ça
vient alors il a beaucoup été question
vous en doutez du nombre de faux billets
gérald darmanin il maintient qu'il y a
bien eu 30 à 40000 supporters anglais en
plus des 20 milles qui eux avaient un
billet valide à ce sont les chiffres on
sait qu'ils sont très contestées puisque
l'uefa n'a recensé qu environ 2800 faux
billets scanner à l'entrée alors comment
on explique cet écart énorme entre les
deux chiffres parce qu'une grande partie
d'entre eux n'a tout simplement pas
réussi à atteindre le point où on scanne
les billets ils ont été filtrées avant
explique le ministre et puis il y en a
d'autres qui n'avaient tout simplement
pas de billets sur eux mais ça ne veut
pas dire que tous ces gens là n'étaient
pas aux abords du stade explique gérald
darmanin qui donc réitère qu'il y aurait
bien eu 30 à 40000 supporters de plus et
il en veut pour preuve les chiffres de
la sncf beaucoup jeudi les critiques et
10 des accords très bien imaginons qu'il
35000 personnes de plus ils sont passés
où ses trente cinq mille personnes et
bien la sncf a elle-même documenté on
vous a également fourni la note qu'elle
nous a fourni qu'à 22h52 c'est à dire au
lendemain de la première mi temps de
très nombreux supporters ont commencé à
reprendre les métros et en l'occurrence
ici le rer d alors face à ces
explications les sénateurs ils sont
malgré tout restées assez sceptique
personne ne l'a vu cette foule
montrez-nous les images de l'hélicoptère
voilà ce qu'ont répondu certains
sénateurs afin que les critiques étaient
également très forte sur l' usage de gaz
lacrymogènes par les policiers à
l'entrée du stade oui ces images elles
ont beaucoup choqué en tout le monde les
a vus 400 millions m2 personnes les ont
vu des supporters parfois calme derrière
les grilles arrosés de gaz lacrymogène
gérald darmanin il a reconnu que le
dispositif de 6800 policiers et
gendarmes mobiles avaient été pensées
pour gérer duo ligue à nice mme mais pas
du tout pour gérer une telle foule il y
a pourtant bien eu une note des
renseignements adressée au ministère de
l'intérieur qui mentionnait ce risque
elle n'a pas été transmise à la
préfecture de police comme elle aurait
dû être sa gérald darmanin l'a reconnu
hier mais ça n'aurait rien changé assure
le ministre car cette note elle
mentionnait quelques centaines de
supporters britanniques supplémentaires
et non plusieurs dizaines de milliers
d'où l'accumulation de 15000 supporters
vers 19h30 au sud du stade dont les
virages britannique à ce moment là il ya
donc beaucoup trop de monde ça devient
dangereux donc le préfet décide de lever
le premier barrage qui est le pré
filtrage pour faire avancer la foule à
ce moment-là il reprit ses effectifs
derrière les grilles pour qu'elle tienne
et la suite c'est gérald darmanin qui la
raconte
pour faire reculer une foule qui va
connaître un écrasement les policiers et
les gendarmes sans doute dans l'urgence
et sous leurs données à la hiérarchie
pour utiliser des moyens de dispersion
est ce que ces moyens de dispersion sont
adéquats pour un événement comme
celui-ci manifestement l'expérience
mérite d'être très largement aux revues
moi je veux dire ici que les décisions
qui ont été prises ont permis de sauver
des vies il ya eu des gestes
inappropriés disproportionnée d'un
certain nombre de la part de policiers
ou de gendarmes mobiles qui ont été
documentés je veux dire qu'il ya deux
saisines igpn en tout cas deux
signalements trésor le darmanin qui
s'est donc quand même défendu qui a
défendu à la stratégie de levée de ces
barrières de filtrage mais ce qu'il a
dans l'autre côté reconnu des erreurs
lors certaines rien gérald darmanin
comme reconnu qu' que les forces de
l'ordre auraient pu mieux faire du bout
des lèvres un peu il a quand même
présenté ses excuses
la stratégie de dispersion des foules
elle va être revu formé de ministres et
on fera mieux pour la coupe du monde de
rugby on fera mieux pour les jo a promis
la ministre des sports j'ajoute enfin
que le gouvernement français a demandé
l'uefa d'indemniser les spectateurs
britanniques qui était muni d'un faux
billets qui n'ont pas pu rentrer et que
les ongles et les espagnols qui ont été
victimes d'infractions pourront porter
plainte depuis leur pays respectif merci
beaucoup c'est bien pour nous avoir
synthétisé expliquer les temps forts de
cette audition au sénat de près de trois
heures raifort j'avais regardé c'est
très fort justement je n'ai qu'un ennemi
qu'est ce que vous en avez retenu est ce
que vous avez été convaincu par ces
explications du ministre écoutez je
pense que que vous avez tout dit la
grosse interrogation portant encore sur
les chiffres de chiffrage des billets ou
de l'absence de billets je ne sais pas
si comme certains à droite comme à
gauche estime qu'il y à un scandale
d'état parce qu'il y aurait un mensonge
d'état ça je suis incapable de le dire d
interrogation se pose en tout cas il ya
une crise il ya une crise d'état il y à
une crise de l'état quand vous pensez
que un simple match de football risque
de provoquer un incident diplomatique on
peut avec la grande bretagne on peut
s'interroger quand on pense qu'un simple
événement sportif et qui sont pas les
géo une coupe du monde pousse le
ministre des sports et surtout le
ministre de l'intérieur à venir
s'expliquer et s'excuser devant une
partie de la représentation nationale en
l'occurrence le sénat et que des
questions se posent sur la la la la
poursuite du ministère de monsieur
darmana et son éventuelle démission on
peut effectivement se poser des
questions sur la fragilité des choses
qui nous entourent et dernier élément
avant dernier élément si je puis me
permettre toute cette crise mettant en
lumière si je puis dire l'absence de la
première ministre emmanuel bord dont la
pratique mental de bandes
lassus significative à mon avis c'était
fait je sers paribas d'elisabeth macron
elisabeth bornes bon je crois qu'elle a
je suis sûre même qu'elle a vus en tête
à tête d'arman monsieur darmana avant le
conseil des ministres hier mais elle a
brillé par son absence donc juste pour
terminer je pense que ce moment là doit
être également interpellé emmanuel
macron qui jusqu'à présent a joué la
stratégie du silence de l'effacement
d'une petite déclaration il a une tout
petite déclaration disant faut laisser
une enquête voilà un petit déclaration
il a secoué un petit peu emmanuel damas
décidément
il est partout il m'a dit gérald
darmanin et son gouvernement pour éviter
de répéter ce genre de choses mais moi
je serai encore une fois et je ne me
suis pas emmanuel macron je changerais
c'est stratégique a été la sienne depuis
la présidentielle jusqu'aux législatives
parce que là aujourd'hui on voit que
c'est la porte ouverte à l'expression
des oppositions de droite qui jusque là
avait été aussi des ré par le chiffre de
l'élection présidentielle sous les
couleurs de domaine mme pécresse et puis
qui permet à la gauche de redoubler
d'entousiasme avec des législatives qui
se profilent dans dix jours donc moi je
dirais méfiance vis-à-vis de l'exécutif
et de la tête même de l'exécutif pascale
tournier ce qui est intéressant dans
cette audition de gérald darmanin c'est
que il a quand même un peu infléchi sa
version depuis cinq jours au départ
vraiment il pointait uniquement la
responsabilité des supporters
britanniques et là maintenant il vient
concédé quelques erreurs de la part de
la police donc finalement il a fait ces
concessions un peu cette pression
médiatique politique oui bien sûr est ce
que je dirai qui et je partirai du point
de départ en fait que je trouve assez
intéressant c'est finalement il a voulu
et c'est super c'était un pari ou pas
j'en sais rien en tout cas il a voulu
tout concentré trouver et trouver une
seule raison et ça c'est une c'est un
procédé de communication presque gérait
je serai pas démago mais j'estime qu'on
a le sentiment qu'il a dit voilà c'est
parce qu'il y avait tant de faux billets
donc c'est la seule explication donc
fermer le ban c'est la pensée père c'est
presque le mur du çon médiatique en
disant ça va ça va écraser toutes les
autres problèmes de responsabilité que
ce soit au sein des forces de l'ordre et
ça a été pour moi l'erreur de départ en
fait de ne pas montrer la complexité
finalement de ce qui a pu se produire on
voit bien qu'il ya plein de choses qui
ont joué c'est bien sûr et on sait pas
exactement quel était le nombre de faux
billets de personnes qui étaient là en
surplus autour du stade de france la
question des transports de la grève est
quand même une multitude de gérer deux
facteurs qui se sont additionnés et qui
ont fait que
tout va tout cas on est arrivé là
aujourd'hui
après la deuxième chose moi je pense
qu'ils et on a qui n'ont pas mesuré
c'est que c'est quand même un événement
sportif qui a été regardé par 400
millions personnes hier c'était quand
même quand on veut c'est là aussi où on
a voulu faire un peu roulé des
mécaniques et maquereau a voulu
accueillir cet événement parce que vous
savez au départ ce devait être à saint
pétersbourg donc pas par un événement de
ce type aussi aussi important on se
prépare on anticipe et là je pense qu'il
ya quand même de ce coin d'huile à un
peu une grosse faille pour venir à toute
autre question de départ je pense qu'il
n'a pas eu le choix effectivement il n'a
pas eu le choix et on voit bien comme
disait très bien très justement janyk
halimi c'est que c'est du velours pour
l'opposition c'est du velours tout est
facile pour pour je dirais il ya tout il
ya des images qui sont là pour pour
montrer qu'il y avait eu il ya eu des
débordements il ya effectivement un
incident diplomatique c'est très facile
pour l'opposition de s'engouffrer et de
et d'attaquer d'attaquer le gouvernement
et d'ailleurs si les sénateurs est bien
lancé une commission d enquête
parlementaire pour l'instant ce n'est
pas du nid en fait on sait qu'ils
souhaitent de des auditions
supplémentaires notamment l'audition du
préfet de police de paris didier
lallement janyk halimi pour vous c'est
de la récupération politique de la part
de la droite de l'extrême droite et jean
luc mélenchon a
coûté avec des tirs de différentes à
chaque fois au nom de la part du sénat
de la part de luc mélenchon ils jouent
leur rôle de contre-pouvoir
institutionnels notamment l'un dans le
cadre de la campagne les autres dans le
cadre de dupes du sénat quoi delà de la
représentation
pardonnez-moi nationale maintenant
effectivement il joue aussi le rôle
d'opposition politique mais mais
pourquoi pas et les choses se passent de
façon je veux dire très correcte des
auditions pourquoi pas ça fait partie de
de la transparence et puis ça permet il
ya également pardonnez-moi l'autre
contre pouvoirs qu'est la justice
puisque indépendamment de l'audition il
y à une enquête diligentée par la
fédération
les fédérations la fédération de
football suisse c de l'uefa je crois et
puis également le parquet qui est saisie
de mémoire outre les les enquête de
l'igpn donc il ya tous les moteurs de
contrôle de contre pouvoir et de
contrôle qui sont mises en activité qui
sont ouverts et et ça fait partie du jeu
démocratique de mon point de vue
tout ça est plutôt sain est plutôt sain
dans les contre-pouvoirs mais encore une
fois le début de cette crise mérite
quand même qu'on s'y attarde
c'est quand on est cantonné au
gouvernement surtout quand on commence
un second quinquennat c'est l'exercice
du pouvoir n'est pas nouveau pour
emmanuel macron toute une partie de ses
ministres et des collaborateurs donc
attention on a bien l'impression depuis
le la présidentielle que l'exécutif n'a
pas d'action ni de réaction tout le
monde est un petit peu perdues
franchement il ya une sorte de faux
plats sains une expression que tout le
monde utilise certes il ya les
législatives m'enfin il est temps il est
temps il est temps d'embrayer sur
quelque chose de plus active de plus
proactifs comme on dit et et de est de
faire en sorte que que que les choses
avancent en france et que gérald
darmanin est sur la sellette avec cette
crise ça a été dit maintenant il a été
il a été conforté semble-t-il par
emmanuel macron pendant le conseil des
ministres est un poids lourd de
la macro ni un poids lourd de droite
dont a besoin emmanuel macron il se
présente aux législatives
est ce que cette affaire va avoir des
conséquences d'ailleurs sur monsieur
darmana mais aussi sur madame bornes et
sur la quinzaine de ministres qui se
présente aux législatives c'est un vrai
point d'interrogation mais l'a
officiellement institutionnellement et
politiquement
dharmanand n'est pas de jardin mana
n'est pas destiné à sauter non mais
c'est vrai que je pense que ce seront
les législatives qui vont être le
vraiment le marqueur en tout cas qui
marquera le un peu le kiki règlera les
comptes si je puis dire notamment les
conséquences
merci pension suivant les conséquences
politiques de cette crise du stade de
français
[Musique]